kevin est victime d'épilepsie après
avoir frôlé la mort suite à des
convulsions au moment de conduire
kevin a subi des opérations
chirurgicales pour enlever une partie de
son cerveau celle qui causaient les
convulsions
sauf que comme l'expliquent le
neurologue robert sapolsky cette partie
du cerveau se trouve être celle qui
réguler et contrôler les pulsions
basiques comme manger et le désir sexuel
quelques mois plus tard kevin fut arrêté
pour avoir acheté et téléchargé de
grandes quantités de contenus choquants
très choquant
j'ai pas envie de parler du gore de ses
contenus mais disons que la quasi
totalité d'entre nous trouvons ce
contenu inadmissible et la quasi
totalité d'entre nous pensons que la
production et la consommation de ce
genre de produits doivent être
sévèrement punis par la loi et la
justice
cependant le cas de kevin est un peu
particulier d'après sapolsky il s'agit
d'une conséquence de l'opération
chirurgicale
en l'absence d'une partie de son cerveau
kevin avait perdu le contrôle de ses
actions mais l'accusation ne fut pas
convaincu l'accusation rétorqua que
l'ordinateur de bureau de kevin que
kevin utilisaient tous les jours
n'avaient pas de tels contenus
kevin avait sciemment choisi
l'ordinateur sur lequel télécharger des
contenus choquants
il semblait donc que kevin était
parfaitement maître de ses choix et que
l'argument de la perte de contrôle
étaient injustifiées
kevin fut condamné à deux ans de prison
il a accepté et même apprécié cette
punition
il est sorti de la prison depuis et
reste en probation et prend des
médicaments pour garder le contrôle de
soi
la justice semble avoir parfaitement
fonctionné sauf que non du moins pas
selon le neurologue robertsau polski
pour sa pause qui kevin est avant tout
victimes des déficiences de son cerveau
sapolsky compare ainsi le cas de kevin
au cas d'un patient atteint d'alzheimer
ce patient peut être en parfaite
possession de ses moyens le matin mais
être incapable de se souvenir de son
prénom
le soir et l'on comprend très bien les
causes de ce phénomène le soir le
cerveau est fatigué et la quantité de
sucre dans le sang diminue de sorte que
le cortex cérébral qui est en charge des
décisions difficiles et qui du coup est
aussi la partie du cerveau qui requiert
le plus d'énergie
ce cortex cérébral cesse de bien
fonctionner et cette défaillance du
cerveau quand il est affamé n'est
absolument pas spécifique aux cas de
kevin on l'a tous vécu quand on a faim
et qu'on est fatigué on est plus
facilement irritable et on a plus de
chance de faire des bêtises
pire encore bien souvent on n'est même
pas conscients de notre
manque de discernement
le cas le plus spectaculaire est le plus
problématique est peut-être celui
découvert par les chercheurs de rigueur
les vagues et afdaim pesos en 2011 ces
chercheurs ont effectué un suivi de 1112
décision de justice concernant la
libération conditionnelle de détenus ce
qu'ils ont découvert c'est que les
décisions des juges dépendent est très
fortement de l'heure à laquelle les
juges prenaient leurs décisions en
particulier après avoir mangé les juges
accordait la libération conditionnelle
dans environ 65 % des cas mais avant le
repas cette proportion de décision
clémente chuté drastiquement pour tomber
à 0 % autrement dit si le juge qui
analyse votre cas est un famille au
moment de la décision vous n'avez alors
quasiment aucune chance que cette
décision soit clémente alors il y aura
peut-être quelques petits bémols à
mettre à cette analyse tamment parce que
l'ordre dans lequel les juges traite les
dossiers pas forcément complètement
aléatoire mais quand on combine cet
effet à ce que jonathan ait nous dit de
la manière dont le cerveau réfléchi
souvenez-vous l'intuition d'abord la
raison ensuite on peut se demander si
les juges sont vraiment conscients des
vraies causes de leur décision mais si
les justifications qui donne à
posteriori ne sont pas que des arguments
ad-hoc pour justifier leur intuition et
tout ça bien sûr ça pose de façon plus
générale la question du libre arbitre
tu y mets mes juges ne sont pas
forcément conscients de ce qui détermine
le plus leurs décisions en quoi leurs
décisions de martel le fruit d'un libre
arbitre
est ce que le libre arbitre existe
vraiment ou n'est-il qu'une illusion
créée par notre inconscient et bien pour
sapolsky plus la biologie avance moins
elle ne laisse de place au libre arbitre
il ya une époque on pensait que les
dyslexiques faisait exprès de ne pas
faire d'efforts pour apprendre à lire
voir une époque on pensait que
l'homosexualité était uniquement une
question de choix du libre arbitre
je vous invite à découvrir toujours plus
d'arguments scientifiques contre le
libre arbitre avec ce superbe vidéo de
david ainsi que des arguments
philosophiques contre le libre arbitre
avec les superbes vidéos de monsieur
fille mais même sans aller aussi loin et
rejeter complètement le libre arbitre la
position de sa poule ce qui ne semble
pas si farfelue imaginez que vous ayez
fait des trucs horribles moment où vous
étiez sous l'influencé d'une drogue
d'une maladie d'un chantage ou que
sais-je encore bref sous la chance de
quelque chose qui vous empêchait
d'exercer pleinement votre libre arbitre
comme dans le cas de kerry oui imaginez
que vous ayez fait des trucs horribles
mais que c'est votre subconscient qui
vous a fait réagir ainsi et à l'instar
peut-être des juges vous ne savez
peut-être pas vraiment pourquoi vous
avez fait ce que vous avez fait pourquoi
vous croyez ce que vous croyez
peut-on alors vraiment considérer que
votre libre arbitre était encore aux
commandes et peut-on vraiment vous
considérez responsable de vos actes et
bien ce qui est amusant c'est que
responsable signifie littéralement être
capable de répondre répondre en
particulier si on nous demande ce qui
s'est passé et pourquoi
et bien en ce sens dans le cas de kevin
d'autres personnes comme les docteurs
qui ont suivi kevin pourra être
littéralement considéré plus responsable
que kevin lui-même du coup est ce
vraiment kevin qu'il faudrait punir
cette question devient plus étrange
encore quand on admet l'absence de libre
arbitre
si on en croit sapolsky david ou
thibault ne choisit peut être pas ce
qu'on pense ce qu'on dit et ce qu'on
fait tout ça est en fait davantage
déterminé par nos gènes
notre entourage social et notre
environnement physique les alors si les
actions immorales d'un individu ont été
entièrement contrainte par les lois
physiques
cet individu mérite-t-il vraiment d'être
puni on peut aller plus loin encore il
me semble que la plupart d'entre nous
suivons plus ou moins la logique de john
locke comme l'expliquent très bien
monsieur fille cette logique est la
suivante
pour john locke la mémoire font
l'identité personnelle c'est-à-dire
l'identité de la personne
la personne est responsable et la
responsabilité justifie la punition donc
en fin de compte avoir le souvenir d'un
crime avoir conscience de l'avoir commis
cela suffit à justifier que vous soyez
puni pour ce crime mais c'est clair que
pousser à bout ce principe est quand
même très bizarre et c'est ce que montre
très bien mais se fit dans sa vidéo avec
une expérience de pensée à base de
téléporteurs dysfonctionnelle mais on
n'a pas besoin d'évoquer des
technologies à la fois inexistante et
dysfonctionnelle pourra percevoir les
limites du raisonnement de l'ocs
les recherches sur la mémoire montre
encore et encore que la mémoire ce qui
fait le noyau de l'identité personnelle
selon bloc est constamment
dysfonctionnelle non seulement on oublie
vite et beaucoup mais surtout on se
souvient de beaucoup de choses qui ne se
sont en fait jamais produite
on a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de faux
souvenirs et ça y penser l'a très bien
expliqué dans une expérience qui va sans
doute faire date
ne faisant que parler à des sujets en
parfaite santé la chercheuse jus lachaud
a réussi à implanter des faux souvenirs
de crime à ses sujets et tout ça juste
en racontant le crime qu'ils auraient
commis et en leur demandant d'y
réfléchir pendant une semaine
accrochez vous à vos slips et là dans
presque 70% des cas le sujet se rappelle
sincèrement de l'histoire qui pourtant
est inventé il va aller jusqu'à se
rappeler des détails qui ne sont pas
dans l'histoire il va se rappeler que le
policier a une moustache qu'il avait les
cheveux de telle couleur qui avait-elle
sont-elles odeurs etc bref tout le
spectre des perceptions intervient pour
donner vie à ce souffle
je vous recommande d'ailleurs très très
vivement l'excellent livre de julia choc
sur les faux souvenirs
ça va vous retourner le cerveau mais ça
pose aussi un problème philosophique de
taille pour l'oc la punition se
justifier par le souvenir du crime
mais julia shaw a montré que le souvenir
du crime pouvait facilement être
implantées si on combine locke ou
découvertes récentes en sciences
cognitives
on serait alors forcé de punir des gens
qui n'ont commis aucun crime et à
inverse
il suffirait d'effacer le souvenir d'un
crime chez un criminel pour qu'il
devienne justifier de ne pas le punir
et là encore les avancées en sciences
cognitives suggère que ce n'est sans
doute pas impossible bref si vous
raconte tout ça c'est pour que vous vous
demandez ce qui justifie vraiment les
punitions judiciaire et pour essayer de
vous convaincre qu'il s'agit d'une
question philosophique non trivial alors
je ne vais pas prétendre répondre à
cette question mais j'aimerais insister
sur la perspective d'un théoricien des
jeux pour la théorie des jeux
la justice n'a pas à décider du mérite
des uns et des autres d'ailleurs on l'a
vu le concept de mérite est loin d'être
facile à définir pour la théorie des
jeux la justice sert avant tout à mettre
en place des incentives pour que les
individus de la société ne se comportent
pas de manière immorale
autrement dit le théoricien des jeux va
inverser la cause et la conséquence au
lieu de dire je punis parce que le
criminel a commis quelque chose de mal
la théorie des jeux nous pousse à dire
je punis pour qu'un potentiel criminel
se ravise et ne commettent pas quelque
chose de mal c'est ce que bruce bénodet
mesquita appelle la causalité inverse
noël n'est pas le 25 décembre parce que
les jours qui le précèdent sont les
joueurs du marché de noël celle inverse
les joueurs des marchés de noël précède
5 décembre parce que le 25 décembre
c'est noël le futur potentiel permet
d'expliquer le passé et c'est un peu ce
qu'on retrouve aussi dans la formule a
essayé le jeu pas les joueurs en se
focalisant trop sur les joueurs on a
tendance à penser que les punitions et
les récompenses des joueurs doivent être
une conséquence de leur comportement
passé au contraire la théorie des jeux
va avoir plus tendance à penser que les
récompenses et les punitions sont des
outils pour aligner les incentives des
joueurs avec l'intérêt de la société et
ainsi amener des individus égoïstes à
faire des choses qui sont bien pour la
société où selon votre philosophie
morale non pas par un altruisme qu'on
leur impose mais par pur égoïsme la
théorie des jeux va considérer qu'il est
difficile de changer la nature et les
préférences des gens mais va profiter du
fait qu'il est possible d'agir
rapidement et efficacement sur leur
incentives alors encore une fois il
s'agit d'une vision très théorie des
jeux du rôle de la justice et en cela
elle est très certainement très
incomplète mais j'insiste dessus parce
qu'il me semble qu'il s'agit d'une
interprétation de la justice souvent
déficiente quand on débat sur ce que
méritent les uns et les autres est
terminée les punitions et les
récompenses c'est aussi et surtout
décider des règles des jeux qui nous
unissent en particulier j'aimerais finir
cet épisode en vous passant un extrait
d'une interview de sapolsky par le
podcast radio la wii fit chou is
something for fun
et enfin à parler de méritocratie je
vous avais demandé combien vous serez
prêt à redonner à alice je vais le voir
la vidéo précédente voire les non c'est
plus précis et donc voici les résultats
la plupart d'entre vous étaient prêts à
redonner quatre ou cinq lingots d'or à
alice est quand même 60 de parts niveau
qui ont répondu plus tôt trois lingots
d'or j'imagine que ça correspondait plus
à 3,33 et l apard égalité analystes
selon l'oie a priori harris ne mérite
pas plus que les autres vous avez été
aussi 31 à dire que alice méritait au
moins six lingots d'or bref je pense
qu'on est à peu près unanime pour dire
que la valeur de chapelets alors
méritocratique de chapelet dans cet
exemple là ne correspond pas du tout à
ce qu'on veut répondre en tout cas tu
tivement vous avez peut-être du coup
envie de dire quelle valeur avec deux
chapelets ça sert à rien mais ce que je
pense que ça montre vraiment et pour le
coup je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'intéressant c'est que quand on juge de
la redistribution méritocratique de
quelque chose ne pense pas en terme de
contribution de chacun la richesse qui
est produite par tous du moins on ne
pense pas qu'à ça théophile panda qui se
nouent demande s'il existe un cas où le
corps et non nul bah oui par exemple il
signa cas alice et bob qui vont chercher
des lingots à la mine toute
redistribution des richesses
appartiendra alors au corps puis puisque
tout ce groupe de travailleurs à ce
moment là c'est juste
alice ou bob et alice ou bob ci sont
tout seuls ils n'arriveront pas à
ramener la caisse du coup alice et bob
s'en sort forcément mieux en coopérant
quelle que soit la redistribution des
richesses que s'il allait chercher la
caisse tout seul plus généralement il
existe toute une classe de problème en
théorie des jeux coopérative où le corps
est toujours non vide à savoir les jeux
coopératifs super addictif c'est-à-dire
qu'ils satisfont cette propriété en gros
un jeu est super addictif
lorsque tout son groupe gagne beaucoup
plus en coopérant tous ensemble que
s'ils coopéraient chacun de son côté
vous tombez nous propose une heure de
travail est égale à une rémunération
fixe alors je veux pas débattre du
principe philosophique et qui est
derrière ça je vais parler des problèmes
des incentives il ya ça reste ensuite à
savoir ce qui est vraiment une heure de
travail et s'il suffit de faire une
heure de travail pas forcément très
productive pour gagner de l'argent bac
tout le monde aura intérêt
pas être productif j'insiste encore
dessus parce que c'est vraiment de thème
de la théorie des jeux en gros et
notamment appliqué à la démocratie à la
politique en général
il faut constamment penser aux
initiatives et à savoir ce que les gens
ont intérêt à faire dans tel ou tel
système
christophe monniot en particulier
souligne le fait que la souffrance au
travail ou à justifier un plus gros
cerfs les typiquement un métier où on
souffre plus on a envie de dire qu' il
faut récompenser plus ça c'est quelque
chose qui apparaît un petit peu dans la
logique économique puisque selon la
logique économique
l'offre est censé rencontrer la demande
donc s'il ya des jobs avec une grande
souffrance a priori il y aura peu de
demandes en ce job et du coup l'offre du
marché devrait augmenter et en
particulier les salaires de ces
personnes devraient augmenter
donc ça c'est en principe si on était à
l' équilibre dans le marché de l'emploi
ce qui n'est pas vraiment le cas pour
des raisons diverses et variées et je
vous invite notamment à les voir cette
vidéo d'oreca sur le revenu de base où
il explique en quoi le revenu de base
pourrait permettre notamment de mieux
faire en sorte que l'offre rencontre la
demande dans le marché du travail c'est
ce qui permettrait une redistribution
des richesses plus conforme à la notion
de souffrance du travail puisque à ce
moment là la demande pour les emplois
avec beaucoup de souffrance devrait
nettement diminué et du coup le salaire
de ces gens là devraient également
beaucoup augmenté et comme on revient
sur des notions qui sont un peu moins
mathématiques et un peu plus
philosophique je sens l'hooliganisme
politique monter en vous du coup à
partir de cette vidéo je supprimerai à
nouveau tous les commentaires avec trop
d'hooliganisme politique par exemple le
commentaire que voici notamment avec des
répliques du genre c'est une
plaisanterie avec énormément de sarcasme
temps vraiment à diviser a stigmatisé ce
genre de commentaires il sera supprimée
à partir de cette vidéo près de feu 0,7
et rémy fiori cherché à distinguer la
notion de méritocratie la notion de
contribution qui est la notion sur
laquelle chapelet c'est vraiment appuyé
à ma connaissance et j'espère me tromper
j'espère que vous le ferez savoir il n'y
a pas de très bonne théorie mathématisée
que ce qu on pourrait comprendre par
méritocratie en dehors d'un cadre de
contribution à société ou d'un cadre où
l'offre rencontre la demande en tout cas
il ya aucune théorie formalisé sur
méritocratie qui a réussi à percer
encadrons 2
la théorie des jeux et ça si c'est le
cas encore une fois j'espère me tromper
ça montre que c'est super difficile de
raisonner sur le concept de mérite on a
tous des notions différentes de ceux qui
le méritent et ça rend l'analyse super
compliqué et on le voit très bien à vos
réponses à la question combien le
méritas liste encore pas mal de valence
donc même sur un cas aussi simpliste que
le cas d'alice
vous voyez qu'on n'est pas tous d'accord
sur ce qu'est le mérite en tout cas de
façon intuitive et du coup formaliser
une notion de méritocratie sur laquelle
tout le monde serait d'accord
vous imaginez que c'est quasiment
impossible et c'est pour ça et que on a
tendance à pas raisonner sur le concept
de mérite mérite
on fait des modèles notamment des
théorie des jeux et qu'on essaie de
comprendre comment fonctionne vraiment
la politique ou comment il devrait
fonctionner non encore du mal à vraiment
trouver des définition rigoureuse pour
définir ce concept qui est en fait
incroyablement ambitieux dit originals
by side et fixe premier critique le
quatrième axe y sommes
alors si je comprends bien ses
commentaires la critique a à voir avec
la notion de statut dans une société
ça c'est pas du tout une critique valide
de l'action' 4 etc sur quatre ne parle
pas du tout de ce statut des différentes
personnes et parle du fait que la
redistribution lorsque l'on considère
deux projets séparément lorsqu'il
considère ensemble doit être la même et
encore on n'a pas du tout à voir avec
les rôles des différentes cartes
bref j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
plusieurs d'entre vous qui sont pas
d'accord avec la valeur de chapelet avec
le calcul de la valeur de chapelet qui
du coup cherche à rejeter un des actions
et c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
un peu cherché à rejeter un des axiomes
en disant bon ben voila si j'ai pas
envie d'appliquer avaient leur échapper
ça veut dire qu'à un des axes homme que
je vais pas satisfaire du coup pour
essayer de trouver au avec lequel de ces
actions n'est pas d'accord alors sans
doute que vous êtes jetés sur l'action 4
parce que c'était le plus compliqué des
ses actions mais j'aurais tendance à
dire qu'il ya aucun de ces actions que
qu'il faudrait rejeter en fait l'action
qu'il faudra rejeté ces l'axiome 0 qui
est en fait le fait que la
redistribution des richesses ne dépend
que des contributions individuelles du
cas moi il me semble que c'est cet
axiome que ma morale intuitive rejette
le fait que la redistribution des
richesses ne doit pas dépendre
uniquement des contributions des uns et
des autres mais ça c'est aussi lié à une
autre notion morale qui est pas juste la
méritocratie mais un certain sens
d'égalité ou d'équité plutôt entre les
différents individus comme j'ai tendance
à associer une certaine valeur à
l'équité
dans les sociétés j'ai du coup tendance
à rejeter la méritocratie pur et dur et
du coup j'ai tendance à vouloir
sacrifier de la méritocratie au profit
d'une plus grande équité
mais il s'agit là d'une critique de la
morale et non pas du concept de
méritocratie jusqu'à pas au sens de
chapelets bref il y aura encore beaucoup
beaucoup plus à dire sur toutes ces
notions sur toute la philosophie qui est
derrière
tu as aussi aussi beaucoup de choses
super un passionnante à dire sur la
logique ou sur l'épistémologie pourquoi
est ce qu'on sait se commencer et ça
tombe bien puisque avec monsieur fillon
n'a lancé à un podcast pour parler de
tout ça de façon plus informelle
ça s'appelle axiom est le premier
épisode est sorti il ya un peu plus
d'une semaine
il est disponible sur youtube et aussi
sur itunes et aussi sur player fm si
vous êtes sur android ce que j'aime
vraiment bien sûr avec somme c'est qu'on
va pouvoir parler de façon plus
informelle notamment dans le premier
épisode
j'ai eu l'occasion d'expliquer un peu
plus pourquoi notamment je te rend cette
plutôt 28 sioniste que platonicien dans
ce podcast en tout cas pour l'instant
entre le premier épisode je peu trop
même pas sûr de ce qu'il y aura dans le
deuxième épisode de pour l'instant mais
dans notre mire épisode un fossile de
revues de vidéos youtube notamment on a
parlé des vidéos de dirty biology de
patience de ma nombril c'est une autre
histoire et une vidéo aussi de pbs
infinite series parce que c'est des
vidéos vraiment trop cool et qui donne
envie qu'on en parle encore un peu plus
et c'est ce qu'on a fait donc sur
actions elle j'espère que vous avez aimé
cet épisode à partir de prochains
épisodes et pouvoir les prochaines
vidéos à venir on va parler de plus en
plus de la morale et en particulier dans
les trois prochaines vidéos on va parler
de l'émergence de la morale thamond
comment expliquer qu'il existe des
individus moreau aujourd'hui à champ car
a priori la sélection naturelle à
favoriser ces individus égoïstes et puis
les derniers épisodes de cette série
seront des épisodes plus de philosophie
morale prescriptive ans et de voir quels
sont les courants de pensée prédominant
pour savoir comment faire
comment organiser nos sociétés et tout
ça si vous avez aimé ces épisodes penser
à la ligue et à le commenter à le
partager pensez à vous abonner pendant
que les futurs des pizzas merci aux ti
peur pour leurs dents et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois cette
activité cérébrale permettait de prédire
si c'était la main droite ou la gauche
qu'elle ait bougé alors ces conditions
je vois pas comment on peut dire que le
libre arbitre existe un si avant même
que j'ai décidé de bouger
le type qui regardent le rmi c'est quand
je vais bouger et il sait si je vais
bouger la main droite pour la main
gauche pour ise de la belle formule de
spinoza cela revient à considérer
l'homme dans la nature comme un empire
dans un empire au sens où dans l'univers
régie par les lois de la nature l'homme
serait comme une sorte de petite enclave
indépendante rebelles où on ne sait trop
pourquoi ces lois ne s'appliquent plus